I wanted to be able to hand people this
album and and answer all your questions
about me you know like what what was he
all about boom here it is hey y'all this
is Walker Hayes and you're watching
certified country with Sophie chalet see
[Music]
happy Friday welcome back to certified
country today we have an interview that
I've been so excited to bring you guys
because I know you know this song it was
can I say it is no secret I'm obsessed
with you broke up with me by Walker
Hayes so listen we already can see that
Walker is crazy talented and easy on the
eyes I'm not gonna lie to you but what
you might not know is that he is married
to his high school sweetheart
together they have not one two or even
three they have six kids and he's the
newest artist signed to Shane Mack and
Ellie's monument records so Walker and I
sat down in Shane's writing room during
my last visit to Nashville to dish on
what just might be the catchiest breakup
ever
I want to talk about you broke up with
me it is one of my favorites right now
what happened when when Shane signed me
you know everybody found out about it
and a lot of people that had vanished
after I lost some previous record deals
we can to come out of the woodwork and
I'm not mad at anybody but there were a
lot of co-writers and stuff who were
like miss you bud and I was like will
you miss me
three years ago you know and so I just
kind of wanted to move on and and I got
with a new team and some some I reply to
all those those people was like hey
y'all broke up with me and I honestly -
my wife and I Lainey we were on and off
again all the time when we were off when
we would see each other in a bar it was
like who could be the happiest to make
the other person mad so there's a little
bit of that you know in the song as well
you know you love it when your ex who
dissed you fight you know sees you
having a good time and you may even turn
it up a little bit when they're around
[Music]
but you are breaking out with a break up
song but in real life you're married
tell me a little bit about your wife and
your family my wife is amazing she's my
high school sweetheart I met her in 11th
grade and we we have we've been on this
journey hand-in-hand held tight together
she's incredible we have six kids
they're amazing three girls three boys
so they're 11 and under right now
separated by two years so they're 11
nine seven five three and one we have a
unique family situation obviously in
this business I don't mean a lot of
people who can relate but it works for
us they're why you know when when Shane
said hey we'll make an album on you my
immediate thought was hey I might
actually be able to take care of my
family doing something I love Walker's
family also serves as the inspiration
for several songs on the album including
this one
[Music]
we dated from 11th grade so right after
college and then we took a year off and
didn't see each other this was back
before Twitter and Instagram and all
that so I couldn't just check check up
but we collided at a wedding I was
singing in it and she was in it and
that's all she wrote I saw her made my
stomach hurt we got back together got
engaged I don't think are there any
other love songs about your wife on the
author yes there's one called Halloween
my favorite song
it's just about me you know growing up
in mobile just trying to fit in as so
many you know kids are I was very
insecure a lot of the stuff I was a big
athlete but but I think a lot of the
things I did were were because they were
mine they were my false identity if you
will you know they they met they they
they got me acceptance and they got me
that attention that I craved or that
kids crave you know growing up but when
I met Lainey I realized very quickly I
didn't know a lot about love at that age
but what I did know is I was a different
person around her but because I was
being who I really am
[Music]
the full album boom is gonna be out
December 8th
tell me about choosing that title so
yeah boom boom is my favorite word like
I love the muscle arm emoji and I love
the knuckles anytime anything exciting
happens for me or my team it will send
it to each other via text and always one
of us is like I say it all the time
you know my kids they mock me there's
they're like boom so yeah so how to be
boom how to be the title you can catch
Walker on the road opening for Thomas
Rhett and Old Dominion right now and all
three of the songs that you just heard
are available right now when you
pre-order boom on iTunes as for me I am
getting ready to head back to Nashville
for next week's episode so don't forget
to Like and subscribe to Entertainment
Tonight right here on YouTube for more
I'll also be on the red carpet for CMT's
artist of the year event on October 18th
you can follow along for all of those
interviews on ET online.com thanks for
watching
[Music]